This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. In 1941, the journalist and screenwriter Leo Rosten wrote, in Hollywood as an Istanbul or Sioux Falls, the rich hastened to express their wealth, and betray their fitful grouping for status, by erecting homes of unnecessary magnitude and splendor. The man who built many of Hollywood's homes of unnecessary magnitude and splendor was Wallace Neff.
这里是《99%隐形》，我是罗曼·马尔斯。1941年，记者兼编剧里奥·罗斯顿写道：“在好莱坞，如同在伊斯坦布尔或苏福尔斯一样，富人们急于展现他们的财富，并通过建造不必要的大体量和宏伟住宅，来暴露他们对地位的不稳定追求。”而为好莱坞建造了许多不必要的大体量和宏伟住宅的人，就是华莱士·内夫。
Neff was a stark attack. I know many people find the term stark attack to pretty contemptible portmanto, but Neff really was both famous in his own right and an architect to the stars. One of his most famous projects was the renovation of Pick Fair, the estate owned by the iconic silent film actress Mary Pickford and her husband Douglas Fairbanks. When the couple moved into Pick Fair, the house sat on a nameless street in an empty neighborhood called Beverly Hills. If you were lucky enough to be invited to dinner at Pick Fair, you might find yourself
内夫是一个……这是一个猛烈的抨击。我知道很多人认为“猛烈的抨击”是一个相当讨人厌的混成词，但内夫确实既是一位享有声誉的名人，也是一位明星建筑师。他最著名的项目之一是对“皮克费尔”庄园的翻新，该庄园属于标志性的无声电影女演员玛丽·皮克福德和她的丈夫道格拉斯·范朋克斯。当这对夫妇搬进皮克费尔时，房子坐落在贝弗利山庄这个空旷社区的一条无名街道上。如果你足够幸运，被邀请去皮克费尔共进晚餐，你可能会发现自己
seated next to Babe Ruth, the king of Spain, or Albert Einstein. Life magazine called Pick Fair only slightly less important in the White House, and much more fun. That's Los Angeles-based reporter David Weinberg. Neff designed a state for Charlie Chaplin, Judy Garland, and Groucho Marx. He designed houses for all three Marx brothers. Madonna, his own-to- owned enough house, Diane Keaton. Who's the blonde from Legal League Blotten?
坐在贝比·鲁斯、西班牙国王或阿尔伯特·爱因斯坦旁边。《生活》杂志称皮克费尔“只比白宫稍微没那么重要，但要有趣得多”。这是驻洛杉矶记者大卫·温伯格的话。内夫为查理·卓别林、朱迪·加兰和格鲁乔·马克思设计过庄园。他为马克思三兄弟都设计过房子。麦当娜，他自己的——拥有过房子的黛安·基顿。那个演《律政俏佳人》的金发女郎是谁？
Reese Witherspoon? Yes. She actually owns the, and we better fact check this, the Libby Ranch in Ohio. Jeffrey Head is an architectural historian, and the author of a book on Neff. I checked, and Reese Witherspoon does in fact own the Libby Ranch.
瑞茜·威瑟斯彭？是的。她实际上拥有——我们最好核实一下——俄亥俄州的利比牧场。杰弗里·海德是一位建筑历史学家，也是一本关于内夫的著作的作者。我查过了，瑞茜·威瑟斯彭确实拥有利比牧场。
At the end of his life, Wallace Neff could have lived in a grand estate on the coast for a huge mansion in the Hollywood Hills. But instead, he lived in a 1,000 square foot, concrete bubble. And Neff believed that this simple dome was one of his greatest architectural achievements. The story of the bubblehouse begins one morning when Neff was standing in his bathroom, shaving. There was 1934, so it was probably a straight razor. Neff looked down and noticed a small soap bubble that had formed on a sink. He reached out and touched it.
在他生命的尽头，华莱士·内夫本可以住在海岸边的一座宏伟庄园里，或者好莱坞山的一座巨大豪宅里。但相反，他住在一个1000平方英尺的混凝土气泡房里。内夫坚信，这个简陋的圆顶是他最伟大的建筑成就之一。气泡房的故事始于一个早晨，当时内夫正站在浴室里刮胡子。那是1934年，所以用的可能是直剃刀。内夫低头看到水槽上形成了一个小肥皂泡。他伸出手碰了碰它。
The bubble held firm against his fingertip. That was the moment the idea struck him. He could build with air. He could build bubble houses. And Neff wanted to build them by the thousands. Near the end of the Second World War, architects were anticipating the post-war, housing shortage and working on various solutions. Neff had a larger view in wanting to create a solution
气泡在他的指尖下保持坚挺。就在那一刻，灵感击中了。他可以用空气建造。他可以建造气泡房。内夫想要成千上万地建造它们。在第二次世界大战接近尾声时，建筑师们正预料到战后的住房短缺并致力于各种解决方案。内夫则有着更宏大的愿景，想要创造一个解决方案
to meet the demand for housing worldwide. Jeffrey Heddes' book about Neff is titled No Nails No Lumber, because the bubble houses needed no nails and no lumber. Heddes says that Neff never saw the bubble houses as a way to make money. He saw them as a social responsibility, a way to provide low-cost housing for people.
来满足全球的住房需求。杰弗里·海德关于内夫的书名为《没有钉子，没有木材》，因为气泡房不需要钉子和木材。海德说，内夫从未将气泡房视为赚钱的工具。他将其视为一种社会责任，一种为人们提供低成本住房的方式。
He really didn't make money from it. in fact, spent a great deal of money from his other architectural practice and put it into the bubblehouses. Plus, Neff was already rich. Remember, he was building mansions for the Hollywood elite, and his grandfather was Andrew McNally, the cartographer who created Rand McNally publishing. Now, Neff's idea of a dome-shaped dwelling was not entirely new. Indigenous cultures in the Americas had certainly explored that territory. Even during Nefs lifetime, another guy, Buckminster Fuller, was creating his own circular
他确实没有从中赚钱。事实上，他把他其他建筑业务赚的大量资金都投入到了气泡房中。另外，内夫本来就很富有。记住，他一直在为好莱坞精英建造豪宅，而他的外祖父是安德鲁·麦克纳利，即创建了兰德·麦克纳利出版公司的制图师。现在，内夫对圆顶住宅的想法并不是全新的。美洲的原住民文化当然已经探索过这一领域。甚至在内夫有生之年，另一个人——巴克明斯特·富勒——也在创造他自己的圆形
solution to the housing shortage, the geodesic dome. Yeah, and I think there's a misunderstanding. People look at the bubblehouse and they think, oh, this is a variation on Bucky Fuller. And it's really not. It's more of a variation on a form appearing in nature that someone has adopted for human scale or human use. What was original about Neff's design was the way the bubble houses were built. Neff invented a new method of construction. He called it aeroform. Here's how it worked. First, a big slab of concrete was poured in the shape of a giant coin.
解决住房短缺的方案——测地穹顶。是的，而且我认为存在一种误解。人们看到气泡房就会想，哦，这是对巴基·富勒设计的一种变体。但实际上并非如此。它更像是在自然界中出现的一种形态的变体，被人类采纳用于人类规模或人类使用。内夫的设计新颖之处在于气泡房的建造方式。内夫发明了一种新的施工方法。他称之为“气模”（aeroform）。它的工作原理是这样的。首先，浇筑一大块呈巨型硬币形状的混凝土底板。
Now, picture a giant balloon in the shape of half a grapefruit with a flat side down. This balloon was tied down to the foundation using steel hooks. So, once the balloon was tied down to the foundation using steel hooks. So once the balloon was tied down, it was inflated through an inlet valve, and it took all of five minutes to inflate it. After the balloon was inflated, it was coated in a fine powder. And this would happen before the gun-night process. Ah, yes, gun-night. Let's take a minute to talk about the magical substance that is.
现在，想象一个形状像半个西柚、平坦的一面朝下的巨型气球。这个气球用钢钩固定在底座上。所以，一旦气球用钢钩固定在底座上。所以一旦气球被固定好，它就会通过进气阀充气，整个充气过程只需五分钟。气球充气后，会涂上一层细粉。这会在“喷射混凝土”工艺之前进行。哦，是的，喷射混凝土。让我们花一分钟时间来谈谈这个神奇的物质。
Gun-night. Or maybe you prefer the generic term, shotcrete. Yeah, so the gunite was shot out of a cement gun, and the gun had two hoses that came together at a nozzle. One of the nozzles had water, and the other was dry cement mix. And the water and the mix came together under high pressure to form the gun ite. When the gunite dried, it was more than twice as strong as regular concrete.
喷射混凝土（Gunite）。或者你更喜欢通用术语，湿喷混凝土（shotcrete）。是的，所以喷射混凝土是从水泥喷枪中喷射出来的，喷枪有两条在喷嘴处汇合软管。其中一条喷嘴含有水，另一条是干水泥混合物。水和混合物在高压下汇合形成喷射混凝土。当喷射混凝土干燥时，它的强度是普通混凝土的两倍多。
Neth loved the stuff. Once the balloon was coated in gunite, a layer of wire mesh was placed over that. Then a second layer of gunite was sprayed on, and bam, that's it. Two men with a balloon and a gun I machine could turn a bare patch of soil into a bubble house in less than 48 hours. And after the gun I dried, the balloon was deflated and pulled out through the front door, so it could be used again on the next house.
内夫非常喜欢这种材料。气球涂上喷射混凝土后，在其上方放置一层金属网。然后喷上第二层喷射混凝土，轰，就这样。两个拿着气球和喷射混凝土机器的工人可以在不到48小时内将一块光秃秃的土地变成一个气泡房。喷射混凝土干燥后，气球放气并通过前门拉出，以便可以在下一栋房子上重复使用。
And Neff claimed that the bubble houses were more fireproof, more earthquake proof, and even more bomb proof than any traditional structure. Neth was so confident in his design that he would often invite people to bash the walls of the bubble with the backside of an axe. Why was it the backside? Yeah, for some reason they used the backside. I don't know what the reasoning was, but I've seen on all the photos they're using the
内夫声称，气泡房比任何传统结构都更防火、更抗震，甚至更防爆。内夫对自己的设计非常有信心，他经常邀请人们用斧子的背面猛砸气泡的墙壁。为什么是背面？是的，出于某种原因，他们用背面。我不知道原因是什么，但我看到所有照片上他们使用的都是
backside of the axe. What Neth liked best about the bubble houses though, was that they were incredibly cheap. After Neff fine-tuned the air-form process, he went in search of a client, someone with money who would hire him to build more bubble houses. And he found one, the federal government. The first bubble houses were done during the war to create a quick housing for government workers. World War II had escalated, and the US needed housing for government workers. World War II had escalated,
斧子的背面。不过，内夫最喜欢气泡房的一点是它们极其便宜。内夫微调了气模工艺后，便开始寻找客户，一个有钱并会雇他建造更多气泡房的人。他找到了一个——联邦政府。第一批气泡房是在战争期间建造的，旨在为政府员工建造快速住房。第二次世界大战升级了，美国需要为政府员工提供住房。第二次世界大战升级了，
and the US needed homes for military workers. So, Neff convinced the government to build an experimental bubblehouse community in a forest and false church for Virginia. In October of 1941, Neff began construction on the 12 bubblehouses in Falls Church that would eventually be nicknamed A Glue Village.
美国需要为军事人员提供房屋。因此，内夫说服政府在弗吉尼亚州福尔斯奇查的一个森林里建造了一个实验性的气泡房社区。1941年10月，内夫开始在福尔斯奇查建造12栋气泡房，这些房子后来被昵称为“冰屋村”（Igloo Village）。
There was no lighting of any kind on the street, and we arrived in the daytime, but it was still quite dark because there were so many trees. Kathy Miles grew up in one of the Falls Church bubble houses. When she was five years old, her dad, who worked for the military, drove the family into the forest to show them their new house. He hadn't told his wife and two daughters that they would be living in a village of bubbles in the woods.
街上没有任何照明，我们是在白天到达的，但由于树木太多，依然相当黑暗。凯西·迈尔斯在福尔斯奇查的一栋气泡房里长大。她五岁时，在军队工作的父亲开车带着全家进入森林，向他们展示他们的新家。他没有告诉妻子和两个女儿，他们将住在树林里的一个冰屋村里。
It was dark and damp and isolated. Then I can remember coming up the street and there was a cleared area with still many trees and very little grass, if any. And there were flagstones and there was this house. It didn't look like a house to me at that time, but there was something rising up from the ground, and it was white and large, and it had two large lumps,
这里黑暗、潮湿且偏僻。然后我记得沿着街道走过来，有一个开阔的区域，仍然有很多树木，草很少，甚至没有。那里有石板路，还有这座房子。当时在我看来这不像是房子，但有什么东西从地面升起，它又白又大，有两个大肿块，
and they were held together in the middle, with a smokestack. And of course, I was with my parents and I don't remember what they were telling me, but I'm sure it was something that we were going to live in this new kind of house. Do you remember what your mother's reaction was when she first saw it?
它们在中间连在一起，带着一个烟囱。当然，我和父母在一起，我不记得他们当时在跟我说什么，但我确信肯定是我们要住进这种新房子之类的话。你还记得你母亲第一次看到它时的反应吗？
Her overt reaction was to stay calm and carry on. I think she was trying to make the best of it and hoping that we wouldn't live there long. So to come to something that looked like this, I think she was truly horrified. The Falls Church community consisted of two single bubble houses and ten double bubble houses. Kathy lived in one of the double bubbles.
她表面的反应是保持冷静并继续生活。我想她是在努力克服困难，希望我们不会在那里住太久。所以看到这样一个东西，我想她真的是吓坏了。福尔斯奇查社区由两栋单体气泡房和十栋双体气泡房组成。凯西住在其中一栋双体气泡房里。
The double bubbles were made by connecting two smaller bubbles with a rectangular center block structure that housed the kitchen in the bathroom. Kathy says that growing up in Igloo Village was incredibly isolating, and it made her stand out. One time when she was in first grade. I set out to draw a picture of my house,
双体气泡房是通过将两个较小的气泡与一个容纳厨房和浴室的矩形中央块状结构连接起来制成的。凯西说，在冰屋村长大是非常孤立的，这让她显得很特别。有一次她上一年级时。我着手画一幅我房子的画，
and of course we colored it and I couldn't color it because I kept insisting there were no white crayons and so when the teacher looked at it she kept saying it's trying to explain to me that I was supposed to draw the house I lived in and I kept saying I do live in this house. So finally, I felt that I wasn't doing what I was supposed to, and she clearly had no idea what I was doing. And the course, when we passed all the houses around to our friends to look at the pictures, the other children left and made fun of it. And so it was pretty daunting as an as an introduction to first grade for me.
当然我们给它涂了颜色，但我没办法涂色，因为我一直坚称没有白色蜡笔。所以当老师看这幅画时，她一直在说——她试图向我解释我应该画我住的房子，而我一直说我确实住在这个房子里。所以最后，我觉得我没有按要求做，而她显然不知道我在做什么。当然，当我们在朋友中传阅大家的画作让大家看时，其他孩子都笑了并取笑它。所以作为我上一年级的初体验，这相当令人沮丧。
And sometimes Kathy would be made to feel like an outsider in her own neighborhood. People were constantly driving into Igloo Village to gawk at the weird families who lived deep in the woods inside strange, habit dwellings. One of the things that all of us, children in the early days, were uncomfortable with, I think, was that when we were outside playing in the yards, people would drive up the street.
有时凯西在自己的社区里也会被当成局外人。人们经常开车进入冰屋村，去盯着看那些住在森林深处奇怪的宜居住宅里的奇怪家庭。我想，我们这些早期的孩子们感到不舒服的一件事是，当我们在院子里玩耍时，人们会开车上街。
And again, it was a dark street because of the trees. And they would drive up very slowly. And as even in the summer as they would drive up very slowly and as even in the summer as they would come up the street they would roll the windows of the car up and they would all be pressed against the glass and you would see them pointing. It was very much a zoo-like feeling and I can even remember when I went to the zoo one time as a child, I remember thinking about how I felt when people were watching me.
而且因为树木的原因，那是一条昏暗的街道。他们会开得很慢。甚至在夏天，当他们开得很慢上来时，以及即使在夏天当他们开上街道时，他们会摇起汽车的车窗，所有人都紧贴着玻璃，你能看到他们指指点点。这非常有一种动物园般的感觉，我甚至还记得我小时候去动物园的一次经历，我记得当时在想当人们看着我时我的感受。
And I thought about how the animals were feeling with us watching them. So it had that much of an effect that I was able to make that transference. Life in the Bubblehouse was especially hard on Kathy's mom. Because there were no straight walls, she couldn't hang pictures or family photos, and the circular rooms were difficult to furnish. But living in a bubble wasn't all bad for Kathy. She discovered that she could easily climb up the side of the bubble onto the roof.
我还想到了动物们看着我们时的感受。所以它产生了如此大的影响，以至于我能够完成这种移情。气泡房里的生活对凯西的母亲来说尤其艰难。因为没有直墙，她无法悬挂画作或全家福，圆形的房间也很难布置家具。但对于凯西来说，住在气泡里也并非全是坏事。她发现自己可以轻松地顺着气泡的侧面爬上屋顶。
I was always a climber, and those days, she called it a tomboy. But on the whole, these houses were really weird. Really, I believe, in this area and it's time, this place, it was kind of doomed to failure. Even though igloo village in Falls Church, Virginia, did not flourish, Neff was still able to land a few more clients. In 1942, the Southwest Cotton Company
我一直是个喜欢爬高的人，在那个年代，人们管这叫假小子。但总的来说，这些房子真的很怪异。真的，我相信，在当时的这个地区，这个地方，可以说是注定要失败的。尽管弗吉尼亚州福尔斯奇查的冰屋村并没有繁荣起来，但内夫仍然设法获得了更多的客户。1942年，西南棉花公司
hired him to build desert colony of bubbles in Lichfield Park, Arizona. The Southwest Cotton Company hired him to build a desert colony of bubbles in Lichfield Park, Arizona. The Southwest Cotton Company provided the cotton that good-year used to make nefs giant half grapefruit balloons. Neff also got a contract to build a bubble-house dormitory for Loyola University in Los Angeles. And in 1944, the Pacific Linen Supply Company hired Neff to design the largest airform ever built. It was 100 feet in diameter and 32 feet high. Neff thought that the Pacific Linen bubble, with its grandeur and prime location downtown, would finally convince the world that airform construction had arrived. Not just because bubbles were practical, but because they were beautiful.
雇他在亚利桑那州利奇菲尔德帕克建造一个沙漠气泡殖民地。西南棉花公司雇他在亚利桑那州利奇菲尔德帕克建造一个沙漠气泡殖民地。西南棉花公司提供固特异用来制造内夫那巨大的半西柚气球的棉花。内夫还获得了一份合同，为洛杉矶的洛约拉大学建造一座气泡房宿舍。1944年，太平洋亚麻供应公司雇内夫设计了有史以来建造的最大的气模。它直径100英尺，高32英尺。内夫认为，太平洋亚麻气泡房凭借其宏伟的气势和位于市中心的黄金地段，将最终让世界相信气模建筑时代已经到来。不仅仅是因为气泡很实用，还因为它们很美。
But still, people just did not want to live in bubbles. Eventually, everyone in America moved out of their bubbles, and they were all demolished. All of them except for one, which happens to be in Pasadena, about 10 miles from my apartment. It was dark when I arrived at the bubble house. It's in a neighborhood of unremarkable suburban houses from the 1930s.
但即便如此，人们就是不想住在气泡里。最终，美国的每个人都搬出了他们的气泡房，它们全都被拆除了。除了其中一个之外无一幸免，这个气泡房碰巧在帕萨迪纳，距离我的公寓大约10英里。当我到达气泡房时天已经黑了。它位于一个由20世纪30年代平淡无奇的郊区住宅组成的社区里。
When I got to the front yard, the sight of it stopped me in my tracks. A smooth dark mound against the night sky. It was a little spooky, but breathtaking. Standing there looking at it, I immediately thought of a passage I'd read in Jeffrey Hed's book. The passage was about this very house.
当我走到前院时，眼前的景象让我停下了脚步。夜空下一个光滑的暗色土丘。它有点诡异，但令人叹为观止。站在那里看着它，我立刻想到了我在杰弗里·海德的书里读到过的一段话。这段话正是关于这栋房子的。
One turns onto a small residential street and is confronted with a house that looks nothing like a house. The fact that it has a front door and a few visible windows only adds to its incongruous presence. Looking at the house which resembles a smooth mound of earth, it feels as if some ancient space station has suddenly fallen from the sky. And upon landing, it has mysteriously embedded itself into the wrong context. Its presence so strange, it seems to have traveled through both space and time. That passage was written by the artist Steve Rodin. Steve knows a lot about the Pasadena Bubble House.
人拐进一条狭窄的住宅街道，迎面看到的是一座一点也不像房子的房子。它有前门和几扇可见的窗户这一事实，只会增加它格格不入的存在感。看着这栋酷似光滑土丘的房子，感觉就像某个古老的空间站突然从天而降。降落后，它神秘地嵌入了错误的背景中。它的存在如此奇异，似乎穿越了空间和时间。这段话是艺术家史蒂夫·罗丹写的。史蒂夫对帕萨迪纳气泡房了解甚多。
For the last 15 years, he's lived in it. The only reason why I drove out here to look at the house with my wife was because the price was so cheap and the image was so strange. And so when we turned the corner and saw this strange brown dome in the middle of an unbelievably conservative neighborhood, it was sort of like what the hell is this? Steve was fascinated by its history and all the surprises that
在过去的15年里，他一直住在里面。我和妻子开车来这里看房子的唯一原因，是因为价格太便宜了，而且外形太奇怪了。所以当我们拐过弯，看到这个奇怪的棕色圆顶坐落在极其保守的社区中间时，就有点像是“这到底是什么鬼东西”。史蒂夫对它的历史以及住在气泡里带来的所有惊喜着迷
come with living in a bubble like the way that light moves across its curved surfaces. What's really cool in the living room at night is when cars drive by and the lights come in through the window. When it projects on the dome form, it's like a crazy, it's like laserium or something, you know? It's really amazing. None of the walls that separate the rooms in the bubblehouse go all the way to the ceiling.
比如光线在其曲面上移动的方式。晚上在起居室里最酷的是，当汽车开过时，车灯透过窗户照进来。当它投射到圆顶形态上时，就像是一个疯狂的……就像是激光表演之类的，你知道吗？真的太惊人了。气泡房里分隔房间的墙壁没有一堵是直通天花板的。
So if Steve's wife is in the bedroom reading, her fingers cast shadows on the ceiling that he can see from the living room. But perhaps the very most badass thing about living in a bubble is the way sound travels through it. It becomes a whispering gallery. When Kathy Miles and her sister were growing up in Igloo Village, they also discovered
所以如果史蒂夫的妻子在卧室里看书，她的手指会在天花板上投下投影，他在起居室里就能看到。但住在气泡里最酷的一点，或许是声音在其中传播的方式。它变成了一个回音廊。当凯西·迈尔斯和她的姐姐在冰屋村长大时，她们也发现了
these parabolic imperfections in the walls, and they use them to send secret messages to each other. I think early on my sister and I learned that if you stood in certain places you could hear people whispering, and if you stood in other places you couldn't, and I remember conducting experiments to see where we could best hear and best not hear, just depending on whether we wanted our parents to hear us or we didn't want to be heard. Steve loves his bubblehouse. He doesn't have the same problems that plague the false church houses. He has custom furniture designed for a circular room, and he's an artist. He likes standing out.
墙壁上的这些抛物面瑕疵，并利用它们向彼此发送秘密信息。我想很早的时候我和姐姐就发现，如果你站在某些地方，你可以听到别人窃窃私语，而如果你站在其他地方则听不到，我记得曾做过实验，看看我们在哪里能听得最清楚，在哪里听不到，这完全取决于我们是想让父母听到我们，还是不想被听到。史蒂夫很喜欢他的气泡房。他没有困扰福尔斯奇查房屋的那些问题。他有为圆形房间定制的家具，而且他是一名艺术家。他喜欢标新立异。
Given how much Steve loves his bubble, we'll get argue that perhaps the bubble houses might have endured a different fate if they were piloted here in California rather than in Northern Virginia. But there are plenty of people who aren't sad that the bubble houses died out, like this guy. I think was a bad idea. Stefano's polysouitas is an architect who's quite happy living in a world without bubble houses. It was a good idea when it came to maybe some industrial uses, but it was a very poor
鉴于史蒂夫对他的气泡房如此喜爱，我们甚至会争辩说，如果这些气泡房最初是在加利福尼亚而不是在北弗吉尼亚试行，它们的命运可能会有所不同。但也有很多人并不为气泡房的消亡感到难过，比如这位。我认为这是一个坏主意。斯特凡诺斯·波利苏伊塔斯是一位建筑师，他很高兴生活在一个没有气泡房的世界里。当涉及到某些工业用途时，它是个好主意，但当涉及到
idea when it came to housing and it made a very uncomfortable dwelling. You know, the light, air, assembly into neighborhoods and so on, it did not vary informed by region, either by culture or by climate or any other way. For Stefano's architecture works best when it takes into account the context of its environment and responds accordingly. Bubble houses are uniform. You can spray gunnights under a grapefruit balloon in Virginia
住房时，它是一个非常糟糕的主意，它造就了一个非常不舒服的住宅。你知道，光线、空气、融入社区等等，它根本没有因地区而异，无论是受文化、气候还是任何其他因素的影响。对斯特凡诺斯来说，建筑在考虑到其环境背景并作出相应反应时效果最好。气泡房是千篇一律的。你可以在弗吉尼亚州
or California or anywhere else, and it's going to look and function exactly the same. One of the shortcomings of this house is that it's really mostly focused on the method of its construction. Stefano's took me on a tour of his office, a Spanish colonial building that he says as an example of great architecture.
或加利福尼亚州或任何其他地方的西柚气球下喷射混凝土，它的外观和功能都将完全相同。这座房子的缺点之一是它其实主要关注的是它的建造方法。斯特凡诺斯带我参观了他的办公室，这是一栋西班牙殖民复兴风格的建筑，他称之为伟大建筑的典范。
He showed me a balcony on the second floor where he and his partner sometimes do work. And it's a favorite place of ours in that we are also urbanists and we dedicate entire life fighting sprawl and trying to re-urbanize the world properly. And we have nothing in front of us here with the magnificent view of sprawl.
他向我和他的合伙人有时工作的二楼阳台展示了一番。这是我们最喜欢的地方，因为我们也是城市规划者，我们毕生致力于反对城市蔓延并试图正确地让世界重新城市化。这里我们面前一无所有，只有城市蔓延的壮丽景色。
This is our frame into the world, you know. It's like a panoramic view of what the rest of the lives are to be about, and to fix all this mess. Imagine if the view from this balcony was a sea of bubble houses. Nothing but thousands of identical industrialized domes, stretching into infinity. It would be a dystopian nightmare for Stefano's. And even though he lives in a world of sprawl,
这是我们观察世界的框架，你知道吗。这就像是余生将要如何度过以及如何解决这一切混乱的全景视角。想象一下，如果从这个阳台望出去的景色是一片气泡房的海洋。除了成千上万延伸到无限远处的相同的工业化圆顶之外，别无他物。对斯特凡诺斯来说，这将是一场反乌托邦式的噩梦。尽管他生活在城市蔓延的世界里，
he has his office to take refuge in. This building is magnificent with a very thick walls. So it's a perfect building for a hot dry climate because when it's 80 degrees outside or 90 or 100, you keep the building tight closed and at six or five o'clock in the afternoon you open those windows and it vents down in no time. Definos explained how the arrangement of the windows provide balanced natural light throughout the entire day. The design was based on the combination of Mediterranean and Spanish styles,
他还有他的办公室可以避难。这座建筑非常宏伟，墙壁很厚。所以对于炎热干燥的气候来说，它是一栋完美的建筑，因为当外面温度是80度、90度或100度时，你把建筑关得严严实实的，到了下午六点或五点，你打开那些窗户，它转眼间就能降温。斯特凡诺斯解释了窗户的布局如何在整天提供平衡的自然光。该设计融合了地中海和西班牙风格，
because Southern California has a Mediterranean climate with Spanish roots. These are the things the Bubblehouse can't do. Be culturally relevant and adapt the environment around it. This office was designed by an architect who spent his entire life designing buildings that did adapt their environment and were culturally relevant to their surroundings. This building was designed by Wallace Neff. A classic Wallace Neff porch. This chair is actually a reconstruction of Neff. This is a Neff design.
因为南加州拥有地中海气候和西班牙根源。这些都是气泡房做不到的事：具备文化相关性并适应周围的环境。这间办公室是由一位建筑师设计的，他毕生都在设计能够适应其环境并且与其周围环境具有文化相关性的建筑。这座建筑是由华莱士·内夫设计的。一个经典的华莱士·内夫式门廊。这把椅子实际上是内夫作品的复刻。这是一个内夫的设计。
It was his office before it belonged to Stéphaneus. I asked Stéphaneus why he thinks Neff did this complete 180 when he created the bubblehouse, why he made something that was so antithetical to the rest of his work. Stéphaneus thinks it had something to do with the birth of modernism. You see, Neff was known for his Spanish colonial houses, white thick walls with red tile roofs and elaborate wrought iron window coverings. They're really popular in California. They're everywhere. But there was this new movement happening all around Neff.
在属于斯特凡诺斯之前，这里是他的办公室。我问斯特凡诺斯，他认为为什么内夫在创造气泡房时会做出这种彻底的180度大转弯，为什么他会做出如此与他其余作品背道而驰的东西？斯特凡诺斯认为这与现代主义的诞生有关。你看，内夫以其西班牙殖民风格的房屋而闻名，白色的厚墙、红色的瓦屋顶和精心制作的锻铁窗饰。它们在加州真的很受欢迎。到处都是。但内夫周围正在发生着一项新运动。
Architects like Neutra, Schindler and Frank Lloyd Wright were making simple boxes of concrete with clean lines and lots of glass. They looked nothing like Neff's elaborate mansions. People were beginning to look at younger architects maybe with, you know, wilder ideas and more relevance maybe to daily life and so on. You think it was sort of like a midlife crisis kind of thing? Of sorts. I mean, I think great architects continue
像纽特拉、辛德勒和弗兰克·赖特这样的建筑师正在用混凝土制作线条简洁、玻璃众多的简易盒子。它们看起来一点也不像内夫那些精致的豪宅。人们开始用带有更疯狂想法、可能与日常生活更相关的眼光看待年轻建筑师。你认为这有点像中年危机之类的东西吗？某种程度上吧。我的意思是，我认为伟大的建筑师一生都在思考
to think their entire life. And there comes a moment in which you look at the movement taking the world over. It's like a wildfire. So you have to ask yourself, am I the wood that doesn't burn? Or shall I become part of the wind?" But the modernists were not impressed with Neff's bubble houses. Steve Rodin, the guy who lives in the Pasadena Bubble House, told me almost the same thing.
总会有那么一个时刻，你看着席卷世界的运动。它就像野火一样。所以你必须问自己：我是那块不会燃烧的木头，还是我要成为风的一部分？”但现代主义者对内夫的气泡房并不感冒。住在帕萨迪纳气泡房的史蒂夫·罗丹告诉了我几乎同样的事情。
Young architects who were trying to bring modernism forward, they thought he was like a dilatant or something. I think he was an outsider probably because he was hobnobbing with movie stars. I mean, imagine if like Barry Manelow started a metal band, it's not like anyone would take that seriously, right? No matter how great it was. I mean, I'm not talking about ironically great, but you know, like, what if it was great?
那些试图推动现代主义发展的年轻建筑师认为他像是个业余爱好者之类的人物。我想他可能是一个局外人，因为他经常与电影明星厮混。我的意思是，想象一下如果巴里·曼尼洛开始组建一支金属乐队，不会有人认真对待这事的，对吧？不管它有多棒。我的意思是，我不是指讽刺意味上的棒，而是说，万一它真的很棒呢？
We none of us would buy into it. And I think that was part of his situation, you know? He wasn't like a hipster. He wasn't an unknown crazy dude. He was a guy with a very strong practice who made giant houses for rich people. And yet, Neff never stopped believing in the bubblehouse. He continued to make variations on it,
我们谁都不会买账。我想这也是他处境的一部分，你知道吗？他不像个嬉皮士。他不是一个默默无闻的疯狂家伙。他是一个业务非常强劲、为有钱人建造巨大豪宅的人。然而，内夫从未停止对气泡房的信仰。他继续对其进行各种变体改造，
designing bubbles with straighter sides and flatter roofs, ones with big holes cut out of the side. Even at the end of his life, long after it was clear that the bubblehouse had no future. He saw it as one of his greatest architectural achievements. He believed in it so strongly that he spent the end of his life living in a bubblehouse. In fact, he lived in the same house Steve Rodin now lives in. Now, I don't want to play the bubble house off as just some failed idea.
设计出侧面更直、屋顶更平的气泡房，甚至在侧面切开大洞。即使在他生命的尽头，早在气泡房显然没有未来的很久之后。他仍然将其视为自己最伟大的建筑成就之一。他对此深信不疑，以至于他生命的最后时光都是在气泡房里度过的。事实上，他住的就是现在史蒂夫·罗丹住的那栋房子。现在，我不想把气泡房说成只是一种失败的想法。
I think it should be a symbol of a design inspired by the highest ideals, beauty, efficiency, affordable housing, a willingness to take risks on crazy ideas to experiment with making the world a better place. Maybe the structure itself, the concrete shell that housed the idea, was flawed. Maybe people don't want to live in bubbles. But their legacy deserves reflection.
我认为它应该成为一种受崇高理想启迪的设计符号：美观、高效、负担得起的住房，愿意为疯狂的想法冒险，尝试让世界变得更美好。也许结构本身，即容纳这个想法的混凝土外壳是有缺陷的。也许人们就是不想住在气泡里。但它们的遗产值得反思。
And so does an F. The guy invented a way to build houses out of air. That's f***ing awesome. And hardly anyone knows about him. And all the remains of his idea is this one last bubble house in Pasadena. Actually, that's not entirely true. It's the last bubble house in the United States. There were bubbles in Pakistan, Egypt, Liberia, India, Jordan, Turkey, Kuwait, South Africa, the Virgin Islands, Nicaragua, Venezuela, Cuba.
内夫也同样值得铭记。这家伙发明了一种用空气建造房屋的方法。这真是他妈的太棒了。然而几乎没有人知道他。而他的想法留下的全部，就是帕萨迪纳的这最后一个气泡房。事实上，这并不完全准确。这是美国最后一个气泡房。巴基斯坦、埃及、利比里亚、印度、约旦、土耳其、科威特、南非、维尔京群岛、尼加拉瓜、委内瑞拉、古巴都曾有过气泡房。
There was an air-form gas station in Brazil. But the largest colony of bubble houses, 1,200 bubbles in one community, was built into car Senegal. Some of them are still standing in all their domed glory. Senegal-based producer Juliana Friend found that they call her bubbles. Juliana said that there's actually a sense of pride among some of the bubble dwellers. In comparison to other buildings in the area, the bubbles are pretty old. They were built before Senegalese independence.
巴西曾有一个气模加油站。但最大的气泡房群——一个社区里有1200个气泡房——建在塞内加尔的达喀尔。其中一些至今仍以其全部的圆顶荣光耸立在那里。常驻塞内加尔的制片人朱莉安娜·弗兰德发现，他们管它叫“气泡”。朱莉安娜说，一些气泡房居民实际上有一种自豪感。与该地区的其他建筑相比，这些气泡房相当古老。它们建于塞内加尔独立之前。
A guy who owns one of the bubbles told Juliana that, yeah, they're hot and uncomfortable, but it's part of our heritage, so I'll never knock it down. So it turns out that it's just Americans who don't want to live in bubbles. Or at least Americans are the ones who can afford to have the choice. Because bubble houses were cheap and required so little material, they were way more practical in the developing world. So, in a sense, Nef actually got what he wanted. 99% Invisible was produced this week by David Weinberg, Sam Greenspan and me Roman Mars.
一个拥有其中一个气泡房的当地人告诉朱莉安娜，是的，它们又热又让人不舒服，但这是我们传统的一部分，所以我永远不会把它拆掉。事实证明，只有美国人才不想住在气泡里。或者至少美国人是那些负担得起、有权进行选择的人。因为气泡房很便宜且所需材料极少，所以在发展中国家它们要实用得多。从某种意义上说，内夫实际上得到了他想要的。《99%隐形》本周由大卫·温伯格、萨姆·格林斯潘和我罗曼·马尔斯制作。
An earlier version of this story was produced as part of KCRW's independent producer project. This episode is part of these STEM story project made possible with funds from the Alfred P. Sloan Foundation. We are a project of 91.7 local public radio KALW in San Francisco and the American Institute of Architects in San Francisco. You can find the show and like the show on Facebook. I tweet at Roman Mars. Sam Greenspan tweets at Sam listens, in San Francisco. You have to go to 99%invisible.org. Radio TIP. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这个故事的早期版本是作为KCRW独立制片人项目的一部分制作的。本集是STEM故事项目的一部分，该项目得到了阿尔弗雷德·P·斯隆基金会的资金支持。我们是旧金山91.7本地公共广播电台KALW和旧金山美国建筑师协会的项目。你可以在Facebook上找到并点赞本节目。我在推特上的账号是罗曼·马尔斯。萨姆·格林斯潘在推特上的账号是萨姆听听，坐标旧金山。你必须访问99%invisible.org。由PRX提供电台小贴士。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。